humph gum resumes welcome back to see
make a speedy huh where her now how did
you Shea find a day you know I go sigh
so McCoy's Tony mondo tell me you come
room one a hotel apostle nah no credito
time I took a loose okay so we're going
back to the classroom funk hmm
they're really jumping character here
man Oh an educator you mean a teacher oh
not this [ __ ] again what Susan motto
Socorro strategy no no no kata Kudo
toasted our total lonely sabe so no
kanji well guess we're gonna have to
feint it
three tomorrow like a certainty if
you're alive now trust that you'll still
be alive then if I recall it's touchy
beerus turned for day to day duty
tomorrow I want to go back to class I
hate the idea that I might not be able
to ever again I swear I'll take my
school work more seriously from now on
oh you [ __ ] Daisy he never came back
did he don't want to [ __ ] anything up
now hello whatever you're facing on a
fly-on-the-wall are just standing in the
middle of the room if you got a hunch
there's something nearby you sex button
never give up the X button why my
panties on oh god that's wonderful
whoever this is seems to have only just
died mere hours minutes early moments
ago
there's an old the crumbled lovely to
pay protection money
well you man guesses as far as you go
excitin has set in so it looks like it's
the end of the road my classmate Tomo
Mizuki climbed the fence around the
actual walkway and slipped into the
woods outside the school it's been three
days now and she still hasn't come back
all the while I've been stuck here
getting chased around by the ghost of a
girl with nothing above her jawline and
add not only twisted my ankle but I also
got glass cuts all over my wrist so I'm
no condition to keep running I keep
hearing this snip snip snip sound of
scissors everywhere I go
I can't tell if it's real or if it's
just a ringing in my ears I wish I just
died already
get it over with so I can find the rest
maybe I can have my head cut off at the
Joel like that Wow wow that's [ __ ] 8
main Oh Oh what is going on I always had
landed squarely in the middle of sea of
broken glass from a fallen light fixture
god damn it the skin between the index
finger and thumb on her right hand was
cut wide out come on O'Connor hinky toss
him up to token what does that mean
sorry damn mi gusta
maybe she should go to the infirmary as
well I don't know I certainly don't like
this oh god what was that sorry sorry
sorry Syrus didn't mean to do that
we're back yeah many banks so I guess oh
yeah I remember we were supposed to go
to the infirmary right let's go there
our doll wonderful then take dolly
through earlier I don't see my hat hello
little friend they're just here mouse so
Donna - don't you wait - husband on you
I don't know does it really matter I
don't think so checking the save data I
only have one slot left
Betty use it wisely likewise loose nuts
ready I see don't read it this is spirit
here I don't see it oh there it is
wonderful let's connect our back away
slowly alright [ __ ] dying I'm not gonna
mess with that guy
well where the hell are we supposed to
go we have a doll now though we do have
a doll
maybe we needed to something
I don't know man I don't it's hurt it
hurts come on where's that coming from
sounds muffled like one of those
Mikado's telephone we got down there
seven is in close what you [ __ ]
why are you crying shut up
why is it crying what is it wine I'll
understand jerk
maybe the Dalek in Elvis maybe the dog
Oh God who are you oh [ __ ] is hurt say
no Aki [ __ ] that girl actually I don't
know yeah oh there's a cheetah in he
told Anna oh my no clue why he is
scoffed no I believe it's him oh it's
him
dodge oka okay babe yeah Sakura my god
okay if you do con Agra huh how do you
get away
hey Gina doe Kodaka gonna get Oh miss
Sidda honey
conky in sorry Tadashi yeah oh you
little nugge Hamamoto daga yes no no he
does the guy that murdered and then oh
yeah yeah that's what I wanna know
sono ato motto is Kyoto day me so me
Terada yo no rou-ha-nee Neko sadita
tsukumo de da de konnyaku bharat on
okinawa demo 30 day yoga oh yeah daddy
yeah no Oh magic abdullah a masseur what
does that mean Abba yeah Kodomo tachi
Nora stories desu demo Sena so Connie
tomorrow koto de Carrera no - revoir
Atacama psychic Asst what
she tell me not Scott Hideki knockin ro
hazardous height:0 coaster honey no dang
get em oh yeah de aquino gotta sauce
soya sauce ma I need to donate hola I
don't know
another sorta that's your motto doc
you're done we knew this already
yes both austero yo Desna misako nachus
a jockeys Escudero mozilla an otaku
knowledge is america toga you mean kill
him cut off his balls
say say gosh aerobatic is in your toe
anata no mater sonicboom continua with
what economist Amano days ah hoo ya
inamorata regina kokoro no your ego
corolla toyota Wow keke Osorio sagusti
Renault the show so just give it to
mother says it it dot it
what okay all right then I'm sorry I'm
sorry I didn't mean it like a heaven sin
fed prayers now basically I'm saying
that's all right now I'm not gonna coach
on otoko Kenyatta's sorry onyx get
across the river
Linda uh-huh alright well if you say so
then
alright yeah that's a that's a good
guess
hey that's not very nice oh thanks
she just left with that she you stay you
know call well we don't really have much
else to go with do we demo
karate Mario yeah sucky konnani yoake
Kyoto t't okay no I didn't proceed only
magical
by Carozza kimochi or in India Donna tan
skinny narrow como judo load a choker OS
tejani no styles Agassi Boyd mio yo ha
ha ha
ties Omega Moroni Ottoman yato Takara
nada Moo's ISA Quinto Gore got ot
terrace in debe de se SAS Giambi Matata
Hotel Ukraina night toy talkie
oh my no kite angered the Tosca ah ha
what the [ __ ] awkward alrighty then what
the [ __ ] was that what was that
something happened hidden Neath the doll
I have cause let us save I'm glad and
what he's back but I was weird like why
would he have to go away anyway they
really change much and we're right why
am I wrong
I'm wearing a thong trust me you'd like
to see it don't you was the point of
that door opening a dozen help me that
doesn't help my quest how about we go
upstairs now that would make sense
don't push me back and say ism goes [ __ ]
you yes it goes never liked you never
alright it's crying hey does that mean
is nearer far away here I don't know for
the kids eyes down from Red Door six
steps [ __ ] thirteen paces rooster 613
rooster what does that mean
alright well let's go to the Red Door
[ __ ] and rooster alright 6 and 13 now
is it right all right let's see here all
right this is the red door I'm correct
which one of the red doors got it nailed
it one of the floorboards hair slightly
raised peering through the crack you can
just barely make out some sort of bag in
the dark
this is below try to pull it off no I
mean yes
what did she do what was that shuffle
you don't shut the doors but a bit of
fidgeting you were able to remove the
item from the compartment it's a small
bag made him hemp and stained liberty
with blood there's a name tag attached
to the friend heavenly host elementary
school Rio your she's our know nanny I
hate delay or meet agree or can't wait
yeah be a gentleman come on what you
arena it's gonna be fine probably the
tongue me give you a little now don't it
dont't it don't don't don't don't do
that
what is it it's the tongue Oh return it
return it
carne GE see oh that was a girl hey
don't strain yourself to those soon uh
you should play catch with it I still
you ha okay why not tongues are awesome
Oh wonderful
Rio's tongue all right where was he
again I kind of forgot he was sitting
somewhere wasn't he
oh yeah infirmary so let's just go to
the infirmary excellent
all righty then a chap would you like a
tongue habanero this whole black medusa
Ayumi produces the boys tongue from her
bag but nothing seems to be attracting
his attention he simply isn't noticing
in order to give him black tongue he
needs to see it well show me cuz
strangle that [ __ ] in front of his head
yeah moody daro me I'll see the question
it's Kiko Rosa Ricardo solo your arm
inference aim serene you oh my who later
Oh Johnny huh job what I got man's gotta
do what a man's gotta do hey be a hero
oh that's lovely
Oh God don't die yeah why we're cereal
why are the blood in hand with Nana
chilled get him
Tojo let's go through the tongue in his
face
oh my oh oh how you got the oh uh oh
look another X Iike su
oh no don't fall in however fine the
hallways you'd open your I'm status
Kenny Kazan martyt crap don't okay Nami
no - Korra a motor-car uh-oh
what is she nice yeah she's nice she
nice yellow voice infirmary isn't
getting firmer down here now this took
me far away first he said it not me
uh-oh cog you all day Donnie Darko Coca
Rock an eye on your side areola Candida
Nami you don't go Coco get to click
uh-oh
alright we're gonna have to go the other
way then son of a bee sting from one way
to go really maybe there may be the doll
from the red doors open now who knows
his knees I guess we'll find out maybe
you watch someone else babies already
you're like oh he thinks red dough is
gonna work that's never gonna work he's
so stupid
he's so silly yeah well in your face so
a sell it oh I love these decisions that
are obvious that they're like me said
psychos she ought to look kiddo sake I
seem to have been in the middle of
texting someone when she dropped her
phone the text window is still open
while confirming the phone's owner sad
as you wound up in advertently reading
the whole thing why way to spy on people
sure cool ah Eamon O'Meara missing I
hope a soda what is she right there's an
erratic noise still with a erratic noise
huh
well what are you gonna do buddy wha
Cody Neeson I do smelly
Yukos Alison et Dona yo you know sake
Madrid 0.8 hora yucca Rajas no vacant so
no God or no yari
Sachi orito Yuka poori Sugino esta cosa
toe non tokubetsu Conoco Sonia Sonia
Toma no no okay in Staten Island oh yeah
why kupo Dania Croix moyamoya asta ship
tecora
no todo sobre taqwa Korra I'm a sense
Nanako yo crap oh no uh-uh no Jetsons
here hola I'm doing laughing okay well
fine
now we can finally get that thing that's
impressive forever
literally
not that be ridiculous I would leave
this forever
plus I wouldn't be playing college money
forever plus that one it's been forever
unless you know forever would be about
eight minutes or so it's she's already
done this I'm gonna get wet
she's already done it I'm on yond only I
wonder what happens if you do it in the
opposite way because it was the same way
I'm using all right it's here I got you
now mother for Konami Ebola
good job Naomi let's go and watch some
videotapes are you teleport outside so I
guess it is for Monica look okay jeez
it'll go
she already done it Sookie sequence una
Soga who are you chimera huh all right
they done that [ __ ] before
ain't nobody mana or okay I tried anyway
let's go in here
yes unlock it yes silly questions man
like no I'm not to share bye dad alright
let's watch his tape not cold room I
wanna watch him oh no that means there's
a ghost in there slinging Jana Isis me
dokoni here no thank you see oh I don't
like this oh god what was that look
sungkyu thank you you didn't Japanese
right thank you
copy ducking on you is about your neck
oh no no don't what oh no school
really when I don't say I don't remember
this this there's a video 8 camcorder
lying on top of the TV it's a cassette
dang it's empty it's bad it's all
sitting there right now I ever nails new
displays and Sabula Otara [ __ ]
endomondo hostage scimitar yeah get
Naruto not really who the [ __ ] cares a
TV living in New York Times Matsui
Tinashe dr. emo Kierkegaard sky no not
really
and we're back so lucky my 1.0 katana
quagga region AO and dad that's the case
suka demo nangka emo no you're a ketose
a dojo Bucca no thanks huh a toria's of
kill no meat at all wow that's nice slap
him ah yeah vena it's more cool knuckle
to suit so always smooth with the ladies
huh let's make soon shall be now let's
do it together you and me baby guarantee
I really hope we don't [ __ ] up this
Claire
chapter getting a bad end it would kind
of suck ass
I have no idea where to go oh yeah she
can't go that way forgot about the line
I'll wonder where the teacher went and
seen her in forever
she was so dedicated to save I didn't
really do anything maybe she will
sacrifice herself in the end it doesn't
even matter okay I'm not light well fine
you know what you don't want to go
anywhere
what about my needs what about how I am
or whatever oh thank you
let's go in here what [ __ ] thing is
still crying go to where the floor
collapse but then get got better oh of
course
Thank You aunty doll one step rooster
ten paces right thank you roosterandrat
110 110 110 110 girl ah ah what the [ __ ]
where did she come from
[ __ ] I think I know where to go
I think this is it yes through the floor
here had clearly collapsed previously
the gap seemed to have mysteriously
closed up in it soon it feels completely
solid that's it
ok 1 1 1 1 1 1 there we go
one of the flower buds head slightly
raised peering through the crack you can
just barely make out something shiny in
the darkness versus below try to pull
out what could it be
probably the head isn't it from beneath
the flower bud you managed to fish out a
crank likey better assembles the window
from an old-fashioned pocket watch what
the hell is that we'll be done on
collision nozzle
you
it's for the dull of course duh no Jesus
I have no idea okay maybe this machine
will work the window you found looks
like it'll fit perfectly in the kill at
the base of the ladder yes it did indeed
slip in device without any trouble but
nothing happened
you got to turn it bra lever is still
stuck but it seems a bit more and give
them need it come on just do it
yes yes yes show that you're a man there
we go that opens what exactly Oh
secrets love secrets secrets are my
favorite thing in the world after
secrets all right let's go there then
fantastic
I wonder how this can address we never
see steaks
no one knows just pushing it again let's
say but like I played this chapter for a
long time let's see one hour thirteen
that's not too bad all right let's keep
going oh good whoa locker room wall it's
called it's called the locker room and
don't be so impressed what's she doing
oh god no oh yeah she can hear them in a
different way
oh no she's nosebleed sugi-dono gal boy
madam Anka maybe just uncle maybe she
should wait outside
oh god it's dripping logica oh no doc
Riga
no okay condom Okyere ter Italian si no
de que hora Korea harmony through the
rock
look there kiddo
nah no H reason you I don't think he
more can I come
okay what is that
what was that dad was totally a ghost
babe I got it how are you doing mate
pocket is crammed full of discarded
underwear all twisted up and wrung out
dishrags that's that's nice
Hey Oh why does it make a noise this is
what make a noise
yeah Jess all right well let's go here
maybe the guys hunting hiding poolside
they are pools kind of fancy school is
this maybe blue cooler you can be in it
Jesus why why what's so scary about the
pool you're looking down I'm leaning huh
look Betty go got my sheets mother done
oh my god waiting us yogi well I don't
like that in boys to be my thrill no
don't do it
hey i-90 got robbed over guy off
somebody ha kidding stick mail I don't
like this idea no no yeah adorable are
we going to the other side is that our
grand idea here
I feel like mermaids are gonna appear I
don't like mermaids Oh murmur village
there's a sign of the door that says
pump room the door is locked
well we better go find the pump then you
can't swim good lord
this is not gonna end well is it oh
hello teleporting thing trying to get
out yes yes let me guess - the pool pump
room yeah right well that's I've had an
F Oh God mermaids what there's a timer
what'd you do what'd she kill herself
what the fire can't swim
I can't it must have been miles would it
be a timer where does she jump oh I
gotta go to the pan room
hurry the bathroom my god go do you ho
snappy snow on my show all right just
Jeff Jeff - dancing
go alright we gotta figure this out fast
Oh God sanic pls sanic powers alright
yes yes please Mike
oh god oh god oh god oh god oh god again
oh god oh god oh god oh god oh god oh
god oh god oh god oh god oh god oh god
oh god oh god again
it's an empty
dad people
oh no no no
please me bad ending
please be bad ending
today dudududud I'm actually glad if you
get the bad ending
yeah wrong ending whatever I'm sorry
high five to you - alright how was I
supposed to do it then
alright press I am very sorry but I have
to end this episode here I do hope you
enjoyed watching please go ahead and
leave a like right now if you did and I
will see you tomorrow with a new episode
Johnson Briss love you